all right today's hey treat male is
interesting in and of itself but also
the introduction is interesting because
we will be talking about pat robertson a
little bit later in the show this is hey
treat male because there are people who
still believe that pat robertson is
capable of having a coherent thought
patriot man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because
freedom so this hatred mail is a sort of
commentary on I don't know how women are
and should be treated and my masculinity
and blah blah blah blah blah let's see
if we can figure out what it is that
this hatred would rather me do let's
take a look I'm sick of brainwashed
unamerican girly men like Parkman
telling us how we should think that they
think that they can lie and lie and we
will want notice telling us how we feel
about as races women and gays what's if
it's right and wrong they have no real
life experience they have zero idea how
the real world works
nice shirt girlfriend this dudes never
been in a fight
never had no money never even had Khalu
says however you spell the hard skin on
your palm from manual labor right
calluses is what this hey treatment so
what is it I should be mistreating women
like Donald Trump in order to be more
manly this type of nonsense is damaging
and that some people really do get peer
pressured by stuff like this into being
rude to others mistreating them etc it's
really really sad as hatred mail often
is but you can turn something sad into
something good because you can use the
coupon code hey tree at forty that's H
eighty are IOT for zero as the coupon
code when you sign up for membership at
david pakman.com slash membership 40%
off your membership for life take
advantage of that